you wrote along with Paul a phenomenal
book
called endless universe and in fact
that's the title of this episode and I
want to ask you we'll get into all your
incredible uh delightful work but that
book is a popular book and I want to ask
you what is the meaning of the title of
the book and what is the cover meant to
evoke in the minds of readers and we'll
show a cover over this so can we please
judge your book by its cover
okay
um well the book was really trying to
convey how exciting it is to be able to
make models of the entire universe and
its entire history
and then test those models against Real
data
um and so I'm always very clear to
differentiate between
theorists which I call imaginary people
and experimentalists who I call real
people thank you and that's a little bit
of a joke on complex mathematics where
you have real and imaginary numbers
but that's really the way I see things
is that the theorist's job is is of
course to benefit from the incredible
observations which are made by people
like you
think a lot about them try to make
mathematical models which fit them and
ideally which make more predictions
which then people like you can check
um most I I want to emphasize that most
of what theorists do is wrong okay and
one of the main sort of in my view most
important things about a theorist is
they should be willing to recognize when
they've gone wrong
um put themselves up to scrutiny to test
both mathematical and uh and
observational and if either fail move on
to a better Theory so although that book
I was very excited at the time we had a
theory which was connecting the big bang
with string theory
and a development of string theory
called M Theory
I was excited about it but at the time
but I have to say uh the more I thought
about it the more I doubted its uh
foundations
and so although I was excited about
endless universe I've written another
book since called the universe Within
that is actually also a popular book
um which again tries to give a picture
of the
what it's like to think about the
universe
but what I'm really excited about now is
almost the opposite of what's in the
endless universe
which is that the point the main point
is that observations of the universe
made by people like you
uh have revealed something incredible
which is that universe is unbelievably
simple
and by simple I mean very economical
in what it takes to describe it you just
need five numbers
um and so far there's no evidence for
anything more than those five numbers
whereas when we look at our theories
they are they have become unbelievably
complex Arcane with a million
assumptions and fixes and starting about
five years ago
um I basically
decided this has all become you know a
bit of a joke to to be honest
uh what we should be doing is being
strongly Guided by the data to
constructing much simpler models of the
universe
and by simply I don't mean uh less
precise or Vega or or anything like that
I mean that basically we the evidence is
we've been missing something
um and I'll I'll go into detail about
what that something is and once I made
this switch As I said about five years
ago I said look I'm just not willing to
build these Arcane models anymore I'm
going to be ruthlessly self-critical
meaning that
I'm not willing to introduce even one
extra field into the standard model
standard model is basically a well well
verified picture of what we know about
physics I'm not gonna I'm gonna be
extremely reluctant even to introduce
one
new ingredient
by that assumption I'm just reeling out
all the models that have been developed
in the 40 in the last 40 years
everybody's been introducing extra
Fields extra particles extra dimensions
you know and what did we end up with we
ended up with the Multiverse
which is the least predictive Theory
ever
okay and uh most predictive well it
predicts yeah it predicts the most but
it's it's the the least testable let's
say
where is the evidence both on the very
large scale and on the very small scale
has gone in the opposite direction so
the Large Hadron Collider you know the
greatest experiment ever built
discovered the Higgs boson
and absolutely nothing else okay so most
theorists like me 99 of theorists are
extremely disappointed at that result oh
my God everything we've done for the
last 40 years has led to nothing there's
just no extra particle to be found
and uh I'm exactly the opposite what my
interpretation is that nature is has
been smarter than we have been
and nature figured out how to get away
with just having the bare minimum you
know the Higgs boson which is necessary
to make uh standard physics work and no
more
so on the tiniest scale we have this
surprising economy in the laws of
physics
on the larger scale it's the same thing
the Planck satellite subsequent
experiments
your
forthcoming very exciting experiment
with the Simon's Observatory you know so
far these have revealed nothing new
uh that's not bad that's that's a huge
challenge for fundamental physics it
says to us maybe we're working on on you
know questionable set of assumptions
[Music]
thank you
thank you